if God was real and if the single all
knowing god yes were to give you a
truthful succinct answer to one question
what question would you ask him if
you're real why is the world so full of
evidence that you're not does that make
you an atheist by definition ostic would
be a softer term CU modern day atheists
are like all up in your face for example
I will defend AD and BC year of the Lord
AD anodin and BC before Christ I'll
defend the use of those because I had a
lot of very interesting science that
went in be it I don't know any atheist
that still uses AD and BC and I don't
have that much objection to the
religious participation in Civilization
it was fundamental and then after that I
would say is the human mind capable of
understanding everything in your
creation I like it if the answer is yes
I go back to the science lab if it's no
I go to the
Bahamas